i just want to make it clear to
everybody there is
no subject that's off-limits free from
the confines of the crown
megan markel isn't pulling any punches
accusing the british royals nicknamed
the firm
of a smear campaign i don't know
how they could expect that after all of
this time
we would still just be silent if there
is an active role
that the firm is playing in perpetuating
falsehoods about us with my wife when
the full interview airs
expect huge audiences massive ad
revenues and lots of shouting at the
television
these are uncomfortable topics for the
royals from the death of princess diana
to racism
my biggest concern was history repeating
itself
back in britain a swirl of rumors
surrounds the royal palaces
with 12 staff members reportedly queuing
up to take part in a palace
investigation
into accusations megan mistreated her
former aides
something she denies but royal watchers
say there's no palace conspiracy to take
megan down ahead of the interview
disgruntled staff it's claimed are
fuelling the fallout
they are low-paid loyal
servants of the crown who work away and
expect in return for
their duties to be treated with a level
of respect they feel
clearly from what's been said uh that
they weren't accorded that respect
they also felt that the palace had swept
their complaints under the carpet
meanwhile the royal family has activated
a tried and tested tactic
say nothing a strategy used after the
explosive tell-all with prince harry's
mother princess diana in 1995
where she revealed details about her and
prince charles's marital affairs
and her eating disorder we decided after
that interview
to say absolutely nothing about it not
make any comment not
um continue the discussion in public
two years later pursued by paparazzi
diana was killed in a paris underpass
and the boy princess age 15 and 12
followed their mother's body through the
streets of london
there's a tension between the royal
family's public persona as
representatives of the 1200 year old
monarchy
and their private lives the tabloid
media often argues that all the
attention they get is completely
warranted because they're public figures
and like celebrities they should just
simply deal with it they also receive a
huge chunk of money 93 million dollars a
year from british taxpayers
meaning every aspect of their lives
their joys their woes and indiscretions
are in the spotlight
parallels have been drawn between megan
and harry and the abdication crisis of
edward viii who gave up the throne in
1936 to marry american divorcee
wallace simpson in time
the popularity of the netflix series the
crown has fueled people's appetite for
the real
royal drama now unfolding on both sides
of the atlantic
with many in the u.s coming down firmly
in support of team megan
especially after the scandal surrounding
prince andrew's questionable ties with
convicted sex offender jeffrey epstein
no palace investigation for that
despite 99 year old prince philip
harry's grandfather recovering in
hospital
after heart surgery there are no plans
to delay
airing the interview behind palace walls
the royals are bracing for impact
neve barker al jazeera london